bonjour C'est Trump votre jeu quotidien
de tous les jours aujourd'hui nous
sommes à Cormeilles-en-Parisis et on va
vous faire gagner plein de cadeaux allez
venez les filles
[Musique]
sur la tes parents venez venez venez on
va vous faire gagner des cadeaux
c'est pas grave dépêchez-vous parce
qu'il pleut et puis elles ont froid
bonjour madame c'est troc croc c'est le
nouveau jeu venez venez
mais c'est pas grave nous aussi on est
en pyjama vous connaissez le principe de
ce jeu bonjour monsieur venez
oui il y a des cadeaux pour vous venez
est-ce que vous êtes joueur
ça dépend vous voulez gagner des cadeaux
ou pas oui allons-y alors dans un des
cadeaux il y a un home cinéma dans
l'autre il y a des bonbons pour les
enfants leur poids en bonbon et dans
l'autre ça n'est plus légumes alors vous
allez pouvoir choisir un de ces cadeaux
mais en contrepartie il va falloir nous
troquer quelque chose de chez vous
est-ce que vous prenez le risque ça va
de quoi quoi
c'est moi qui choisis ça sera c'est vrai
ah oui c'est moi qui choisis
pourquoi ça va être compliqué non il y a
plein de trucs à prendre ici prendre le
bébé par exemple j'en avais plein le
viens viens
de bien vouloir vous faire signer le
papier comme quoi vous êtes d'accord
pour troquer un de vos objets contre un
des cadeaux
[Musique]
tac il a signé allez alors il y a un
jaune il y a un bleu il y a un rouge
lequel choisissez le bleu tu es sûr le
bleu ok elle a choisi le bleu bon bah
maintenant c'est moi qui vais choisir
avant de savoir ce qu'il y a dans le
paquet venez les amis il y a pas un truc
que votre belle-mère elle vous a offert
que vous avez pas du tout envie de le
garder
dites-moi pourquoi ça le biberon non non
un verre un verre non non je vais
regarder le canapé il a l'air bien dit
non
il est bien le canapé dis-donc
ah ouais il est bien canapé et si je
vous prends votre canapé
s'il vous plaît
vous voulez pas goûter
les beignets
allez hop
c'est mes déménageurs
c'est top non
hop merci beaucoup bah maintenant vous
allez voir ce que vous avez gagné alors
vous donner un grand coup pas sur la
fille pour casser le truc
ce qu'il y a dedans
c'est bon ah c'est les bonbons des
bonbons venez les enfants
on passe des enfants
les enfants on en a combien ici
pourquoi pourquoi vous écoutez pas
pourquoi elle est trop petite
kilos tu fais 40
pour une lampe 49 kg
un cadeau lundi viens pas si si viens
viens écoute papa pour une fois laisse
toi vas-y combien tu pèse
25 kg et ben vous avez gagné 25 kg de
bonbons
on va ouvrir une boutique et surtout
c'est l'anniversaire de la petite poule
c'est pour toi oh là là
on ouvre une boutique
merci merci alors ça vaut le coup non
oui surtout que la lampe elle marche
ça fait quelque chose c'est gentil un
bisou et bon anniversaire à bientôt
allez au revoir tout le monde et vous
m'enverrez la note du dentiste
[Musique]